at the end of time
[Music]
13 o'clock
hey everybody what's going on it's
Wednesday again like I said it seems
like it was just Wednesday holy crap
seems like just a week ago or no it
seems like just a week ago it was a
weekend yeah
seems like just a week ago no I was
gonna say it seems like only yesterday I
was like you know putting on that new
intro and seeing that little baby hand
which cracks me up every single time the
little baby hand at the beginning
but yeah hi it's it's Wednesday
everybody seems very excited about this
topic and I can't remember I think one
of you guys I think it was one of you
guys like recommended it and I'm really
glad you did because I didn't know jack
[__] about this case like I had heard
the name like vaguely but I didn't
really know anything about it and when I
started looking into it I was like holy
crap this is like bat [__] I can't
believe I don't know about this and I
can't believe it's not kind of more
widely known because this is a crazy
[__] story I think I remember
something about this but I'll probably
remember details as they come up yeah
Zach said I never heard of this one but
cool yeah this is uh it's worth it it's
a crazy story uh Danny Rowling said Mr
ballin's YouTube channel did a video
about this case yeah I watched it I
watched um I watched his one Simon
Whistler did one
um and then this girl what the [__] was
the name of her Channel I can't remember
I listened to it on the way home from
work in the car but I watched like a
bunch of there's not a huge number of
them but because like I said it seems
like this one's not really all that well
known in spite of how crazy it is
because it's like not only does this
involve like a serial killer but it's
also like a group it's like a cult like
a sex cult and there's like Aztec [__]
going on in it it's it's crazy it's
crazy
it's already starting to sound familiar
but there's I think there's more than
one that was kind of like this yeah
there was a dude that had one too for a
while
I think they were uh killing people for
certain cartel members and sacrificed
them to get the blood I don't remember
exactly now see this one didn't have
anything to do with cartels or anything
like that because this actually took
place in the 60s okay okay
and well and also it's kind of one of
the rare very rare cases I mean
infinitesimally rare of a female sir I
guess you could technically call her a
serial killer she was really only
convicted of two murders but that's only
because they couldn't get anybody to
testify against her
um they think she may have murdered as
many as 15 they're thinking
um it's usually I usually see like
between 8 and 15 something like that but
she seemed
um I mean the way that it happened is
actually really fascinating too because
we can kind of get into the psychology
of that but it's one of the very rare
cases of a female killer who seemed
sexually motivated uh which hardly ever
happens I don't know if she I mean I'm
guessing there had to be a sexual
component to it I think it was probably
like so like a Power Trip as well but I
mean the [__] that she did and that she
got other people to do um yeah I'm
imagining there was probably like a
large sexual component to it so again
that's very very unusual and I think
that's why a lot of people are kind of
fascinated by this case yeah that it's
probably where I've heard stories of
these Mexican
uh all female cartel uh type gangs I
think they were assassins I think that's
really how they were making the money
and that was like one of their little
blood rituals after they'd kill these
dudes they would have sex with the dead
bodies the girls would
I don't know exactly how that happens
maybe they just ride his face I don't
[__] know but I remember hearing
something about that that's modern maybe
they got some of that [__] from these
old cases maybe yeah maybe that idea of
getting the ideas from them yeah
xanadas said I'm familiar with this case
Mexico has some crazy true crime stories
yes and this is one of them yeah uh
curly says to be called the serial
killers have over five victims I thought
it was three three last I heard uh I
think the FBI categorizes three like I
said she only got convicted of two but
they're pretty sure that she did at
least eight improv possibly as many as
15.
um and so
I I feel pretty confident calling her a
serial killer I mean considering like
what they know about her and like what
she [__] did but um let's see Camp
guy said does anyone remember the name
of the case where a mother and teen
daughter were abducted at a Boca Raton
high-end shopping mall parking garage
and driven around with blacked out swim
masks ooh I kind of do know what you're
talking about I'll look that up though
because that sounds like hauntingly
familiar what happened to him
they just drove around with the swim
Mass I got well I don't got any more
doing that well yeah
yeah he said I saw it on Unsolved
Mysteries okay so I'm gonna put Boca
Raton
swim masks that'll that'll
clip my memory in
but yeah so um
yeah that thought that would happen in
Florida yeah Boca raton's in Florida
so uh so yeah that's that's where it
happened and I kind of feel like uh that
I probably should know about that one
because I should know more about Florida
crimes but you know what I mean
um
yeah curly said a sequence kill is three
yeah this one happened
I don't know I guess you could call her
a serial killer but it was also it
wasn't all just in one big it was kind
of like just one extended period it was
like a six week period
you know what I mean so it was almost
kind of like a
I don't know what would they what a
spree killing I want to say free killing
I want to save but I don't know it
doesn't really kind of fit either
category
uh Zach says there was a Mexican serial
killer case from last year that got some
attention Andreas Mendoza it's super
[__] up yeah I think I've heard that
name too I need to look that up also I
need because I'm always looking for more
stuff to like put in the polls you know
yeah we need to do some Mexican cases
yeah because yeah I feel like we don't
really do enough
there's a lot of good stories from down
there well yeah and we have
some uh some listeners
who are in Mexico and could probably
help me out and you know I know some of
you guys are here tonight and I'm sure
I'm gonna pronounce some of this [__]
wrong so
I tried it okay so the Aztec goddess I'm
not gonna say yeah but the Aztec Goddess
that um that factors into this story
I've looked up this video because I've
heard it pronounced like a couple of
different ways and so I looked it up and
I found this video that said how to
pronounce it with real world examples
and there were like five real world
examples and every single [__]
on there pronounced it differently and I
was like well that's super helpful thank
you very much for that so I'm not
entirely sure like how to pronounce it
but I'll try to do
I'll try to get it as close as possible
uh murder Hornet said have you all done
a show in the South American lead mask's
deaths I thought we did like the lead
masks case we might not have done a
whole show about it but I think we
folded it in with another one like it
was a double feature I think I remember
putting it in the polls
um and talking about or something but
it's like I don't remember if we ever
actually ended up doing it or not
but it would have been under let but I'm
pretty sure we did it if we did do it we
did it like with another topic you know
what I mean do you do stuff on dictators
we do stuff on pretty much anything
that's interesting True Crime stuff
paranormal stuff weird historical stuff
whatever like interesting people [__]
up we did a show about uh I'm trying to
think of like some of the more unusual
ones we did but I'm kind of drawing
black it's kind of drawing of like
um Camp guy said talking about the swim
masks thing they never caught the guy he
killed one set of mother and kid and let
one set go yeah
Danny Rowling said the villagers of this
town had [__] for brains uh they did but
I mean in their defense
they lived out in the middle of nowhere
uh they weren't educated uh they were
really poor and they probably believed a
lot of um you know dumb mythological
[__] like a lot of people did back
then Superstition yeah especially in
that always ends up biting you in the
ass I feel like I always end up biting
me in the ass don't believe in [__] like
that it's just a pro tip because [__]
like this will happen because it's like
it wasn't just because the thing about
Magdalena Solis is that it wasn't just
her she like was able to persuade all of
these people to do this really [__] up
[__] really [__] up [__] Zach said
um did you ever talk about Pedro Lopez I
don't think so now I'm having to write
all this stuff to him
you guys did Rasputin yeah we did do
Rasputin that's right
and uh who was I trying to think of that
we did the other day
um
John Wilkes Booth we just showed about
John Wilkes Booth
yeah we did do Rasputin didn't we it was
a while it was a while back but yeah I
don't remember if we ever did like the
assassination like the um Anastasia like
the romanovs or anything like that
because I know that's kind of like we
deleted I thought we did too but it was
like a long time or it may have been
inside the Rasputin that's what yeah
because that's kind of like related to
that so we might have talked about it in
there they overkilled none of them
survived well they they didn't find that
out until a lot later though but that
was like a yeah that was a big mystery
for a long time but until they finally
like found the other bodies and did all
the DNA and everything they were like
yep that that woman that said she was
Anastasia was not [__] it was all
[__] the whole time fantasy yeah
well you know what are you gonna do
she's trying to pull one over that's
can't blame some people for trying to
like [__] drift I guess
but uh yeah so Hugo's here says hello
guys uh
fast food killer murder Hornet said
serial killer Paul Reed in Nashville I
was in the same jail as him in the 90s
aka the fast food killer I don't know
that one I don't think I know that
either isn't it like and I think I've
said this a bunch of times because like
when I was working on my faceless
villain books and I was just kind of
like you eventually have to come up with
some kind of like filter to like filter
stuff out because otherwise you'd be
writing about crimes like for the rest
of your life because you find ones and
then there's like then you go down this
rabbit hole and there's billions of like
other ones yeah homicides are common
there's like well and even like not even
just regular ass homicides I'm just
talking about like [__] up ones like
serial killers and stuff like that
there's like you know everybody knows
like the kind of Big Ticket serial
killers but then there's like all these
obscure ones that did really messed up
[__] too and it's like hardly anybody
ever thinks about him and I don't really
know I don't really know what makes one
famous and not another one you know what
I mean the media has a lot to do with it
I guess but it's just because we've done
some shows on some serial killers that
aren't as well known as some of the
other ones and I'm just like I don't
understand why this isn't better known
than like Ted Bundy or something like
that because some of these people did
like [__] just as bad you know so I
don't know timing yeah timing in the
media I'm whether or not it catches on
yeah weird uh Danny Rowling said didn't
some kid alert the Mexican authorities
about killing taking place in a cave in
this case yes uh that kid is a hero um
and will
talk about what happened to him though
because uh spoiler alert wasn't good is
there anything
um any shout outs or anything we gotta
do to start I don't think so is there
anything that you would like to
come up on say anything about your
adventures at the at the bike biker
thing or anything like downtown Sanford
um
that's all motorcycles
I put some stuff on Instagram
took a few videos probably about 70 or
80 bikes showed up
it's pretty good we'll see it it happens
on Thursday too oh does it yeah it's not
are you gonna go tomorrow night I don't
know probably not I mean I don't think
we're not streaming tomorrow night so
you can if you want but I might just
swing by it's not an official bike night
but they're down there anyway
[Laughter]
a couple nights they they focus on you
know yeah because I was pretty sure yeah
Tuesday night was kind of like the big
night that because I know mannequins was
doing a whole bunch wrote in they were
only there until about nine and then
they leave because they go to another
bar so they almost go on a tour
they don't drink much well they probably
have to get up and work in the morning
too and you gotta ride a motorcycle
which I'm imagining is even worse than
having to drive a car
depends on how long you've been doing it
I guess also you got a new necklace
which is cool oh yeah yeah
it's got a jam
um
Viking wolf on it and a bunch of runes I
don't know what the [__] is this
if somebody they can read Roots like
told you what I said what if it says
something really [__] up some little
dick energy yeah
holy [__] wouldn't that be funny oh my
God if I hilarious [__] if I could if I
could write like Viking ruins or
Egyptian hieroglers or something like
that I would be making so much [__]
jewelry like that and I would make it
like super Metal and badass but then it
would say stuff like that like I'm a
giant [__] I recognize I think a name
in there I think it said fafnir or
something like that I think it was I
think it was one of [__] or one of
them
want one of Odin's wolves
and [__] yeah I don't remember what it
was
uh
mill near was the name of the damn
hammer
uh emu and E newer I don't remember I
can't really pronounce her that was the
names of his Ravens
yeah and I think and I think the uh I
think the Wolves had names too I I don't
remember what they were though I think
it started with f but you I I think I
recognized the name in there but I
forgot what it was what I said
murder Hornet talking about the serial
killer Paul Reed he said he was a huge
mofo his neck was the size of my thigh
who was this Paul Reed the serial killer
look up images of Paul Reed and look at
his neck big neck small head
day rolling then says that uh the whole
part of the kid alerting the authorities
of the cave killings in this particular
case that we're gonna be talking about
reminds me of Dracula Untold and the
cave vampire kinda okay yeah maybe so
maybe that's kind of where they got the
idea from this because this all most of
this took place in a cave and
like I said this is a crazy [__]
story and I'm surprised it's like not
better known I didn't really even know
about it but one of you guys I don't
remember who it was but one of you guys
like recommended it and it finally won
in the thing and I was like
yeah this is nuts I don't I don't know
why more people don't know about this so
uh so yeah so let's go back to the
beginning okay so we have to start
before we start with Magdalena sillies
we'll come back to her in a moment
because there was a whole
framework or a whole thing leading up to
this
so I kind of feel like this is another
one of those cases we talk about this a
lot when we talk about serial killer
couples you know because we've done
several shows about that
and I'm always kind of curious as to
whether had the woman been left to her
own devices and not met the dude
would she have killed people anyway
probably not most of the time this woman
I the situation where it took place was
so specific
I don't think she would have turned out
the way she turned out had the situation
not gone this way because
um circumstances in this case went like
in exactly the wrong way to turn her
into a monster pretty much and I think
if those circumstances had not been
present she would I'm not saying she
would have been a great human being I'm
just saying that she probably wouldn't
have done anything this
monstrous or this horrific you know what
I'm saying so it was all a bunch of
things that
ended up in a particular way I don't
think anybody and like you know meant
for it to end up this way but it did
so before we get to her we have to talk
about these two dudes named the
Hernandez Brothers
and their names were Santos and cayetano
now these two Schmucks were basically
they made their living just kind of like
wandering around from town to town in
Mexico and scamming people
um they were pretty much they were good
at kind of like sleight of hand like
simple magic tricks [__] like that so
they would go around to various towns
and you know tell give people a line and
[__] like that and just try to scam
money out of them so that that's
basically how they made their living
so I'm not entirely sure how they found
out about this one uh town where they
ended up going to where all of this uh
stuff took place which is called yerba
buena uh in Mexico
but this town
um it was a tiny tiny little town I have
seen
um it was basically I think that it was
like 20 families maybe so I think it was
I've seen between 50 and 70 people like
it so it was a village essentially
and I heard that um it might have been
like The Mexican government or the
government of that particular state of
Mexico like sent all these families out
there to kind of like farm the land
because I guess the land was pretty good
uh the the land was kind of fertile but
it was like a really really small town
and it was just all of these people that
lived there they all knew each other
they were all kind of related and stuff
like that and they just went there and
farmed the land you know growing bean
and corn whatever beans and corn
and um you know as usual this was a very
uh isolated Village it was kind of like
at the foot of some mountains uh the
people there were you know hard working
but we're not very educated many of them
were illiterate
um the Land There was pretty fertile and
they did grow stuff and were able to
like sell it at market and stuff like
that but still it wasn't like a huge
amount of money so a lot of them were
kind of like scrabbling for money
so somehow
subsistence farming yeah pretty much is
what it was
so somehow uh right around 1962 like the
end of 1962. the Hernandez Brothers
heard about this town
and I guess I'm not really sure entirely
like what their end game was I think
that maybe they were kind of like well
we're not making a [__] ton of money
just going from Podunk town to Podunk
town just like you know um scamming a
couple like old ladies out of their
money or whatever and maybe they thought
it would be a good idea
to go to this one town and see if they
could kind of like take it over but the
weird thing about it is that I was like
well this town your bobwena doesn't
really seem like the best place to go to
do that because like I said everybody
there was pretty poor it was very small
it was only like Max 70 people that was
like as many people went there so maybe
I don't know I don't know exactly like
what appealed to them in particular
about this town but they decided um that
they were gonna show up there and uh
pull one of their scams I don't know if
they had done this scam previously I'm
guessing not but maybe this was kind of
like like I said maybe they were kind of
going off on a power trip kind of thing
so what they did was they go to this
place
and they basically roll up into the
center of town
um you know and they're strangers so
everybody comes out and it's like who
the [__] are these guys you know like
looking at them
these two guys basically say
um we're prophets of these powerful
Incan Gods which
um they're a little geographically
challenged there because obviously the
Incans that was Peru and we're in Mexico
should have been Aztec they got it right
later on but um but the when they first
came they basically like were emissaries
of these powerful
Incan gods and uh we're here to give all
of you villagers a message
that you pretty much have to do
everything we say because you know the
gods are speaking through us and
everything and if you do that
um then you will be rewarded now
apparently at around this time period I
don't know about now
but in this time period in this part of
Mexico there were a lot of uh stories
about gold like in the in these
mountains like in these caves and stuff
that were in these mountains like right
around this Village
so I guess a lot of the townsfolk
believed this
um so basically I think the brothers
came in and were like hey you know the
gods will tell you where all this gold
is like Untold riches and all this other
stuff
um if you basically do everything we
tell you to do and if you don't then
like the gods will punish you and it'll
be really bad and stuff like that
so
sadly and probably not surprisingly
pretty much everybody in town believed
it and we're like okay well what can we
do for you then sirs
um turns out that what these guys wanted
was they basically wanted to be treated
like [__] VIPs man they wanted a
place to live they wanted to be weighted
on hand and foot
and because you knew this was coming
they also wanted some sex slaves
so I mean you know you knew that was
good enough one of the first things I
mean well the first thing they said was
like well you have to give us all your
[__] like you have to give us all your
stuff now like these people didn't have
much but they did have some stuff you
know what I mean they did have some
possessions and some money and stuff
like that he's like okay we're gonna
need all of that
um and then so you know the townsfolk
were like okay here you go because they
thought they were gonna get like piles
of gold in return you know what I mean
so they gave them all their [__] and
then they're like okay well now you're
gonna have to give us your you know
daughters and wives and various other
things now it wasn't just they used
um some of the girls and women and we're
not just talking about the women we're
talking about girls too like little like
14 year old girls and [__] like that
not only were they using them as sex
slaves and guys too they didn't really
seem uh that particular they were just
like whoever
um but they also some of the ones like
the younger girls and stuff like that
they actually made some money by
essentially selling them into sex
slavery in other towns like in
neighboring towns so they started doing
human trafficking essentially uh so
there was that
which you know not not great
now to think about it so
also they started getting everybody into
um orgies you know as one does
and how are they doing this well like I
said they come into this town I'm not
really sure like I said I'm not sure
exactly what their end game was other
than because like I said they were scam
artists yeah how many of them were there
just two of them just two two brothers
yeah Santos and uh coyotano was the
other guy's name
and I you know I'm sure they probably
targeted this Village in particular
because it was so isolated and cut off
from the rest of the world and he's like
maybe these people are really ignorant
and you know we can tell them anything
and we'll just get all their [__] and
you know to their credit that did work I
mean they must have known that's been
dumb as rocks who to fleece yeah well
like I said they lived out in the middle
of nowhere and they were like really
poor a lot of them couldn't read and all
this other kind of stuff so then you
know as you mentioned they were very
superstitious so they probably believe
anything you know two strangers show up
and say hey we're emissaries of like ink
and God they'd even know that like the
Incan gods were like not even from there
right you know what I mean okay so it's
like well I mean to be fair the the
Hernandez Brothers didn't know that
either because they should they could
have should have come in and said Aztec
well like I said they said Aztec later
on like they got it right later on
because maybe they realized their
mistake but they were just like whatever
these people don't know the difference
and they didn't so yeah
so yeah so they come in and it's sad I
know it's like because I was thinking
this too like when I was reading the
story and I was like it's very easy to
like victim blame
um you know kind of all these poor
farmers and these two dudes show up and
go hey we're gonna give you all the gold
in the world all you have to do is give
us all your [__] and let us [__] all
your daughters and wives that also sell
them into sex slavery and everyone's
like okay can you do it sounds
reasonable it sounds reasonable right I
mean it's you have to think too that
maybe they were kind of like desperate
for money you know and we talked about
this a little bit when on a couple weeks
back when we were talking about the
televangelist show it's like how can
anybody just keep sending money to these
people that are just obvious scammers
they must have been people still do it
must have been pretty uh charismatic too
these guys it must have been somehow
they they were able to convince these
people that they were emissaries from
Mayan Gods
the Aztec gods you know it's looking
crazy that is pretty crazy but like I
said if they believed it I mean they
were already primed to believe that kind
of stuff and maybe these guys knew that
so yeah so they started putting together
some orgies
um you know as one does and uh got some
drugs they got some they got some weed
got some peyote yeah made some peyote
tea got everybody tripping balls and
like having little ceremonies and stuff
over the emissaries of the Gods well
yeah they're totally coming and they're
gonna give you guys gold this is all
generations young and old I guess so I'm
not clear on because I read a bunch of
stuff about this and like I listened to
a bunch of different podcasts about it
no one is super clear on how many people
in the village went along with this
because to be honest at first I thought
it was all of them right
um but I guess it was just like it must
have been most of them though because
there wasn't really that many people in
the town yeah so must have been a select
group that fell for it maybe a couple of
different families a couple of families
did it and the way that [__] goes down
like later on I kind of found it I I
think that maybe the implication was
that everyone kind of got ripped into it
at some point because if you after a
certain time period if you didn't like
you got you know
you got uh in trouble okay you got
killed okay so um so yeah so I kind of
feel like so I don't know how many
people initially believed it
um or you know if just some of them
believed it or everybody I don't really
know
so yeah
for a little while the two brothers are
having their you know drug-fueled orgies
and whatnot uh with all of the
developing cult members the cult never
had a name or anything like that but
that's essentially what it was the Aztec
sex cult yeah pretty much
um you know so it goes on like that for
a little while
but then
um
it's pretty much like some of the
villagers were like you know when the
guys first came here
they promised that if we did all the
[__] that they said like you know
massage their feet and gave us they gave
them their daughters and stuff like that
that we would get like a whole [__] ton
of gold right yeah I mean where the [__]
is the gold at I mean we're still broke
yeah so that's really not what they
promised right
so I guess they were kind of starting to
Grumble about it
so at this point uh the Hernandez
brothers are kind of like well [__] um
we probably need to like up our game a
little bit like you know get to kick
this into high gear is what they're
trying to do
so they figured what they were gonna do
is they're gonna go to Monterey nearby
they said we're gonna find somebody
who will
pretend
to be
um a goddess or a God either either one
I don't think they were all that
specific
so they go to Monterey and um apparently
they they found
um they found
um Magdalena through her brother
um Eleazar eliezar who was um you know
her brother also her pimp
so your brother was her pimp well yeah
um Magdalena and I'm not excusing
anything that she did but uh from what
they know of her childhood it was it was
pretty pretty it was pretty terrible
so I guess I think the Hernandez's new
hymn from their human trafficking from
their common human trafficking business
and he said hey I have a sister who is
also a sex worker now Magdalena had been
uh essentially I guess like put into
prostitution like I've heard 12 I've
heard 14. but she was young I mean she
was really young when they started
pimping around
when her brother started pimping around
now at the time of this story I believe
she was about 18 years old I've seen
some sources say that she had married at
this point but I don't know I don't hear
anything else about the husband and he
never comes up again so I don't know if
that's true or not there's like I said
there's some details that are not super
clear about this because it happened a
long time ago
so
they say to Magdalena they're like okay
we want you to come to this Village
and pretend to be an Aztec goddess we're
all going to go in on this together and
her brother um Eleazar he's like yeah I
want to be on this in on this [__] too
because I want to get on the get on the
gravy train pretty much
so what they did
was they take Magdalena
and they dress her up like they get this
costume that has like a [__]
headdress and there's just this crazy
like maker look all like because they
they'd figured out Aztec by this point
they had abandoned the Inca thing
so they figured out the Aztec thing so
they get her like a costume and all this
other kind of [__]
and they suffer in this cave
like up in these mountains near this
town where they've been having the you
know the the sex orgies and the drugs
and everything
so then the Hernandez is go to the town
and they're like uh you guys you guys um
of the whole town you guys all need to
come up to the cave like right now
because it's time for you know a ritual
it's time for a ritual and the townsburg
are like oh yeah it's that time isn't it
so they all go up there but unbeknownst
to them uh this was going to be a very
special ritual I guess the Hernandez is
didn't I tell them that
what they did was they hid Magdalena
behind this rock or whatever like in her
get up
and then they had some like flash powder
you know because like I said they knew
some like stupid little magic tricks and
whatnot that would impress people that
didn't know anything about anything
so they kind of they do the ritual like
you know and they're chanting and all
this other kind of [__] and then Eleazar
comes out and the townsfolk don't know
who he is he's you know magdalena's
brother and he's basically I'm the
prophet of the of the goddess and bloody
blah and she's gonna come here tonight
and everything is like really okay and
then bam there's like this huge
explosion like the cave fills up with
smoke and then she pops out like in her
get up and all the talents broker like
what holy [__] there she is you know
what I mean like they totally bought it
they totally bought it I don't know how
good this costume was I don't know how
good this flash powder was I mean it was
dark in the cave and their defense
but uh you know what I mean
so they basically said that she was
um the ancient goddess and I'm sure I'm
gonna pronounce this wrong because this
is the one that I watched the video and
they pronounce it like five different
ways it's like kawat
liquu okay I've also heard kawat La cue
okay not sure so I don't know it
basically means skirt of snakes or she
with skirt of snakes uh they have
statues of this goddess it's a real it's
a real Aztec guy I mean she's not real
obviously but it's a real like
mythological one so basically yeah so
she's got like this skirt she's pretty
badass looking actually so she's got
this skirt that's made of snakes and
she's got a necklace that's made of
human hearts hands and skulls which
again pretty pretty metal and
um she seems like
uh kind of a fertility goddess but also
like a mother goddess she was the
Goddess that gave birth to the moon and
the stars and also uh gave birth to the
god of sun and War who is
something like that you could probably
pronounce it better I put it there with
like the little things everything in the
story with tilapati kills her
sacrifices oh yeah I don't know that
might be a very use your arms and legs
off tourniquets or arms and legs off
with snakes and cuts her arms and legs
off
and then berries are in the ground from
her correctly and it it causes something
else to happen I forgot that I forgot
the story but there's a pretty famous
um Aztec statue
a round disc that they found buried
of it almost kind of looks like a
swastika but it's her in the Middle with
all her arms and legs cut off and
they're tourniated with with snakes but
she's kind of like in the form of a
swastika kinda it's kind of round oh I
think I know what you're talking about
yeah I think that's that same goddess
you're talking about I think I think
Wichita I think sacrifices her yeah so
that's like his that's his mom yeah it's
his mom yeah yeah she's like I said
she's also and she also like had birthed
the moon and the stars so she's kind of
a big deal
I think she's a good and good analogy to
her would be
in biblical because the contexter and
wet or in Middle Eastern religions she
would be Tiamat
the [__] space Dragon basically and
disassembles her and from her body
creates the universe
that's a very very common thread
throughout a lot of Worlds mythologies
is the you know God but there's also one
like keep people killing like um gods or
whatever like killing their parents yeah
that's a big thing and also forming the
world from like body parts from like a
cut up God that's very very common yeah
like across many many mythologies memory
serves your this this uh this goddesses
is the same one that's on that that got
cut up I think yeah maybe for sure I
know would you like to killed that one
did she have a snake snake skirt on we
had a bunch of snakes in the imagery
yeah she was tourniquet it up with
snakes
and then the one the one statue that
they have of her on Wikipedia
is they're not sure if it's actually
supposed to be her like in entirety or
if that's just like her her snake skirt
because the top of it where her head
would be is two snake heads like facing
each other and they're like they're not
really sure if that's like her actual
head or if that's just like what she's
supposed to be wearing or if it's just
like a fanciful representation or
whatever but like I said it's pretty
badass looking
so that's who they said that Magdalena
was that she was this powerful Aztec
goddess uh murder Hornet said how they
sneak her in the village without Nobody
seeing her that's what I'd like to know
see because I'm not entirely sure how
far away this cave was from the actual
Village so I don't know if like the
villagers could actually see the cave
from where they were like they could
just like look out the windows of their
Huts or whatever and be like hey what
the [__] going on over there you know
what I mean it might have just been a
thing where the you know that you
couldn't see the cave entrance or
whatever and they just like stuck her in
the cave without them seeing and then
called everybody up there I'd imagine
but they all fell for it anyway I mean
that's the long and short of it and uh
yeah
so basically
what ha what ended up happening so
Hernandez brothers were just over the
moon about this because they're like woo
these dumb ass villagers they like
totally believed this [__]
however
what they didn't count on
was that Magdalena
was a straight up crazy
[Music]
and I'm not entirely sure
I mean I have some theories about maybe
what the psychology behind this was
but very very soon after this whole
introduction
of her and her realizing that all of the
villagers actually did believe that she
was a goddess
she either became completely delusional
and started to believe it herself
or was a complete psychopath and thought
I'm going to milk every [__] thing I
can milk out of this maybe both things
I'm not entirely sure I mean I'm not
inside her head so I didn't know what
she was thinking it's possible that she
could have just been completely crazy
might have gone delusional power went to
her head well yeah and what I was
thinking was that and I heard a couple
of other podcasters bring this up as
well and this is probably like a good
point is that like I said not excusing
it but Magdalena
um apparently did not have like a real
good childhood obviously she'd been
pimped out
as a prostitute from a very very young
age and so it's speculated that because
she probably felt like she never had any
power in her life yeah no now all of a
sudden everybody is looking at her like
she's an all-powerful goddess and doing
whatever she says
and sucked it right in yeah and I think
that that's pretty much what happened
um which is pretty horrifying when you
think about it because when when you
kind of like think about this case the
whole the entirety of this whole
situation you know lead getting into
like the [__] that we haven't got into
yet like the really horrible [__]
it all took place over a six week period
so we're not talking about years we're
not talking about anything like that it
was just like a few it was like a month
and a half
and she got people to do [__] that you
would not think that you'd be able to
talk normal people into doing well look
at Jonestown well yeah and like yeah you
know what I mean that's but that
happened over a longer time period I
mean to be honest to be fair and then
and that one
started out like with good intentions it
seemed like and then just like the frog
in boiling water this one it was a very
very truncated very short time period
and pretty much from the beginning
um it was pretty [__] up
so what ends up happening is that
Magdalena
either believing she's actually the
goddess or thinking I'm gonna run this
[__] now
she basically took it over
took over the whole cult
I'm not really sure
um what the relationship between her and
her brother and her and the Hernandez
brothers were like how they were just
kind of like let her do it maybe they
just thought oh well maybe they got
sucked into it too and they just kind of
got dragged along or maybe they thought
hey our grift is working let's just you
know keep it going they didn't want to
like pull the brakes on it or anything
like that and then by the time it got
like super [__] up it was too late to
quit I'm not really sure like how that
ended up happening but it was just like
this big Whirlwind of [__] [__]
so she was basically like okay so not
too long after she took over
and uh started doing she she continued
the drugs and the orgies and everything
like that she even started doing well
she would start
um cutting herself like blood red
bloodletting and putting blood in um you
know chalices and whatnot and then she
would mix peyote in with that prior to
that they were you know drinking the
Peyote and tea
but she's like no everybody's got to
drink this now so it's like vampirism
yeah that's all Aztec and mine stuff
yeah well yeah yeah that's I mean that's
what they started getting into that
somebody mentioned in there that the my
that the Mayans are cooler than the
Aztecs the Aztecs were mines they were
kind of every everybody in Mexico and
even below down in Central America in
that period And before in general you'd
say that they were Maya they're Mayans
but they were organized in city-states
kind of like everybody in Greece were
Greeks but they had their own
city-states some of them are Athenians
Spartans Spartans were Spartans but they
were Greeks it was the same thing with
this
the
the Founding Father of the Aztec Empire
was it was a Mayan you got driven out of
a dam
out of his city-state for sacrificing
his daughter on wedding night had her
skin alive and the skin worn by a priest
and he and it was a gift the daughter
was a gift and he you know the priest
was wearing it in front of the father
didn't get you it was some kind of
religious thing and you know they were
tripping balls
the founder of the Mayan empire was a
[__] psycho they did a lot of I don't
understand it so the rest of the minds
drove them out deeper into the desert
until they found a place where there was
a
there was some kind of Prophecy
evidently
where they were they would know where to
live when they uh would find a [__]
eagle eating a snake on top of cactus
and that's they eventually found that
over in Lake what was the name of that
Lake like uh
[__] anyway like [__] yeah that's where
they decided to put their capital and it
was floating it was a floating Capital
out in the middle of the water like an
island they made the island bigger and
bigger and bigger until the [__]
water disappeared snazzy Advanced well I
don't think it ever actually did
disappear because the Spaniards attacked
it from from the water they put a
[__] Spanish [__] warship in it
but uh
it was a floating city
and even had floating gardens you know
pretty advanced
and then uh from there they've they
formed an Empire that was but their
Capital City floated
had [__] causeways and [__] going out
to it it's easy to defend because they
could
cut the draw the cut cut the draw
Bridges or you know what I mean pull up
the draw Bridges and there's no way to
get to them
and they would be and they were even
growing their own food out there so
from that Fortress basically they
basically enslaved all the other Mayans
city-states around them and they became
part of the Aztec empire so you could
say it was a splinters group of the
Mayans
but they were mine
in the same way Spartans
we're Greeks even though they were
killing hellots I mean that was putting
their [__] pot which were all the
Greeks you know what I mean they just
like whatever you're just there we don't
like you you can't think of things in
terms of Nations States the nation
states and citizens didn't exist these
were all tribal
tribal tribes and running city-states
pretty much yeah
Senor sticks has just arrived hi Tom and
Jetty hi Zach asked if it was Lake
Titicaca might have been that's what I
was thinking too but it's like
I didn't say it because I thought I
thought you'd laugh at me no I know that
I know that name but there's more than
one Lake I think it might be Titicaca
but I think there was another one thank
you Senor sticks yeah thank you very
much for the Super Chat
Danny Rowling said that Village should
have had a neighborhood watch group to
spy on the [__] from the get-go
and other things engines
yeah um yeah I'm not really sure why
they didn't like I said I don't wanna
you know just because you're dumb that
doesn't mean you deserve to have this
happen to you but you know I mean
who was it that said I can't remember
like who said this quote but it's a
pretty famous quote something like um
I'm paraphrasing but um
anyone who can make you believe
absurdities can make you commit
atrocities does anybody know who said
that yeah it was it was something like
that it's a pretty it's a pretty famous
quote that's not exactly what it is but
it's something like that
um
Senor 6 is asking what doctor is the one
to seek for HRT
uh oh it's sidetracked oh [__] your
local one that's easy to find just
Google local HRT Clinic Google near me
and just Google it it'll show you
um
they'll show you the ropes don't stay
with them long you know it's expensive
there's ways to get it a lot cheaper if
you got [__] crypto you can get stuff
you can get whatever you want
but let them teach you the ropes
that's how I learned
learn to give yourself injections and
[__]
yeah but you better have about 700 in
hand
and it's going to cost you about 200 a
month
for a good one a cheap one might be a
hundred but they might be giving you
[__] they're not giving you
HCG and stuff you know because it's not
just tests it's ACG you want that too
you can use Clomid too but HCG is really
the way to go even though I don't hardly
use any of that anymore just use a test
I let everything just shut down [__] it
I run a little bit of Clone but keep
everything working if you guys don't
talk about you know your debts you know
they don't have to be working 100 just
enough to [__] keep them from
Vanishing
yeah you want them running away yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
it depends on what you're doing at the
time
at the time you're not going to have any
children come on
Zach says maybe Tom is thinking of
tuanaku the only reason I know about
them is because I used to play the Tomb
Raider games
Tom played Tomb Raider too low yeah I
played almost all of them over the years
I've never played the new one I like the
Tomb Raider games well I like watching
them I don't really like playing them
it's too stressful
but you know what I mean it's it's
actually even stressful for me watching
them like he's supposed to like jump in
and like falling from like Great Heights
and stuff I'm just like ah even though I
know it's not a real person you know
what I mean
so yeah uh let's get back into that oh
James says I haven't heard that quote
before Jenny but that seems like a lot
of uh LBJ sayings maybe I don't that
doesn't sound right but I can't if that
very well might be who it is I can't
really remember I just remember like
reading that quote a long time ago and
being like Oh yeah but I can't remember
who said it
um yeah okay so Magdalena that like I
said she's getting them to drink her
blood mixed with peyote you know that's
a party
and also she's continuing the whole orgy
situation and it's starting to escalate
um to a point where she seems to be
getting off on watching
um the villagers commit incest with one
another uh pedophilia
bestiality damn so there's some of that
yeah uh they did animal sacrifices too
because of course they did
um killed goats and drank their blood as
well
but yeah so she's basically making
people have sex with their relatives
have sex with animals
have sex with children and she's like
watching all of it okay name of the
Aztec capital city was was uh tenno
teach lawn and I was right it's not like
Titicaca it's Lake zoshimilco
okay well there you go oh no excuse me
text to Coco
that's that's the lake that it was built
on
all this on blood peyote I guess well
blood peyote and uh and religion yeah
like actually believing she was a
goddess can you imagine an 18 year old
I don't know if she was illiterate I'm
presuming probably
um an 18 year old former sex worker who
had been pimped out since she was you
know a teenager and suddenly everybody
will just do whatever she says I can't
imagine what that would do to you cycle
I imagine she's [__] had all a lot of
[__] kind of bitterness so she's just
making everybody [__] everybody that I
was thinking that too you need to screw
your mom and you need to screw your
daughter yeah because there's all kinds
of weird [__] like that and like I said
not excusing it but she probably had a
lot of really horrible [__] done to her
so she's probably like I don't even know
these [__] people and they'll do
anything I say so yeah and you're gonna
screw the dog that kind of weird [__]
yeah so she was probably like doing
since she had some anger issues bro yeah
yeah I'd imagine
so she's kind of yeah so she's like
getting off on like watching all these
people doing this James Knapp said uh
Jenny I looked it up it was Voltaire oh
okay that makes sense that makes sense
it was Voltaire okay
so yeah so she does all that
now after you know a little while of
this like a week or two I'm presuming
apparently two
is the villagers were kind of like you
know man I I don't really like this I
don't really like having to have sex
with goats and my sons and everything
like that's [__] up right that's like
yeah or am I alone here it's [__] up
and the other guys just yeah it's like
yeah it's a little [__] up too I don't
I don't really like this like how are we
gonna like extricate ourselves from this
situation right so these two guys are
just kind of talking what was the
enforcement method well you're about to
find out okay
so these two guys start kind of
grumbling about it and I guess word
starts getting around that these two
guys are dissenters Heretics as the case
may be
and uh Magdalena finds out about it
so at the next little ritual they're
having in their little sacred cave there
she basically points right at him and
said those two are dissenters kill them
damn and everyone in the village and
this is like their family members and
their friends after everybody knows
everybody it's like 50 70 people
something like that
and they did it damn they just beat him
to death yeah yeah they just [__]
jumped on him and [__] beat him to
death damn without hesitation
they did not hesitate she just said
they're dissenters they're saying bad
[__] about me it's like they need to be
punished like [__] kill him right now
and everybody did they just did
something kind of like
they all have skin in the game
they're all committing all these weird
atrocities on each other and all this
weird [__] so it has to be true
and if anybody stands up and says hey
man this is not right all of a sudden
you're making them feel guilty so they
[__] turn on you and attack them no
it's yeah that's true yeah
um that's a good point so they became
part of the crime yeah that was like
when Saddam Hussein took over his
country he would just pick out random
people because they're all Traders and
then the people who weren't
who weren't picked out as Traders would
go it's not me because he was calling
them out name yeah name after name and
and then they start clapping everybody
who was basically
freed or you know no longer under threat
started clapping yeah good job good job
we're not Traders things yeah you guys
are so loyal tomorrow you will act as
the firing squad on these guilty ones
Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah from then on out he
controlled the country because those
they had killed dudes
they couldn't back off of it right
Saddam knew exactly what he was doing
yeah yeah and I kind of feel like maybe
I don't know man in this situation
so it might have been something like
that yeah you know what I mean like and
they've been committing all these sexual
atrocities and [__] and with the two
people that called them out so you got
to get rid of them or you'll be guilty
so yeah or everybody will find out about
yeah they'll find out it's like we'll
all get in trouble and then soon as they
killed those dudes they were [__] in
it balls deep there's no way backing out
now
yeah that's kind of the point in our
return yeah beating uh your your fellow
villagers today possibly family members
yeah
Zach said so she's fluffing Her Muff to
all the greatest hits classy yeah
yeah I mean see what this is
because she was getting into one she was
getting into like watch all these people
do this [__] [__] oh that's the
classic the greatest hits yeah yeah the
greatest hits yeah bestiality yeah
all this [__] you're not supposed to do
yeah it's all the taboo [__] yeah which
everything else had been burnt out in
her she'd done everything else so uh
yeah I guess she's like yeah it was like
some marketing right yeah I guess that's
what it was yeah
and now it's murder
yeah so so they beat the two guys to
death now in some of the sources
um she had in anticipation of this
moment had kind of like buried some sort
of Pikes
in the dirt like in the cave hung them
up from the Pikes drained their blood
out into
the chalices
mixed it with chicken blood and more
peyote I don't know where they were
getting all this peyote from it was it
grows there well I know I'm just kidding
um but it just can't smell good they had
a bunch of weed a bunch of weed good did
you ever did you ever like um engage in
any blood rituals while you're around
peyote
ah just you uh you mash it up and drink
it yeah they like I said previous said
they were drinking it you see until she
got the idea yeah you eventually get
sick throw a lot of it up some dudes
will put it back in and to hit it again
okay no that's a little much it's like
LSD kind of not quite as strong it's
like I don't know it's like can't you
just get more peyote in order to like
read you know you're not a dog don't be
like be able to [__] you barfed up you
might be able to smoke it that's gross
we just ate it gross yeah
but yeah so um so yeah so she mixed it
with chicken blood and peyote and then
makes everybody drink it
you know basically like yeah we got rid
of those dissenters where all you guys
are all you guys are all okay
now so basically after this like I said
I don't know if she actually believed
that
a lot of the sources that I read said
that she actually came to believe that
she was this goddess and that she needed
human blood to like live forever you
know what I mean and I'm not sure if
like the uh the brother started
believing that too because it was a it
was a crazy situation there's a lot of
drugs were involved
um a lot of heightened emotions let's
call it that so everything was just
chaotic I'm sure so maybe they're
starting to believe all kind of crazy
[__] and there was kind of like a group
Synergy going on too because I guess
everyone was kind of like into this
unbelievable well you know some dudes
were getting the [__] that they've been
trying to get all their lives and [__]
too you know what I mean like man I
finally got a crack of her during this
ritual so some people are probably
enjoying this oh I'm sure yeah having
these orgies and [__] yeah they're like
all right I'll go along free drugs and
free sex all right I'm in yeah yeah and
free love and [__] right and then until
until she says hey go [__] that goat wow
[__] that goat you're not gonna be able
to [__] that chick okay
[Laughter]
goats even mentioned yeah okay well they
well they started sacrificing goats
before and then they had sex with the
goats yeah yeah there was there was
bestiality okay so it's mostly goats as
far as I know okay yeah might have been
other animals too I'm not really sure
what other animals goats and Village
dogs probably probably yeah horses and
[__] whatever ones or cows if they had
those whatever ones forever whatever
they had
chickens
that might be a little difficult that
one saw a [__] clip so he put put up
on I [__] where the [__] was that
but it was somewhere it was somewhere in
India
somebody's [__] filming the [__]
monkeys running around in India their
monkey ran and [__] grabbed a chicken
and started [__] it look at the
chicken
the Chicken Guy look at that chicken
chicken got away though because like
what the [__] are you doing you're not
my species monkey tried to [__] the [__]
oh it's funny calm down
monkey got a little excited yeah
chicken rape it was a young monkey
it wasn't a full girl monkey it looked
like look like a little one
from chicken
takes off
maybe that that was like the monkey
equivalent of Gonzo because you know
Gonzo the Muppet like he's super into
chickens even though he's uh what is
gonzo is he she's a bird right of some
kind is he a vulture I don't know
he's a blue thing he's I think he's
supposed to be kind of what's Oscar the
Grouch
what is a Monster yeah I mean Sesame
Street they you know in their defense
like a lot of their puppets were just
monsters what was Grover he was also a
Monster yeah okay like a lot of them are
just monsters you know I mean like yeah
big bird was a bird and snuffleup guess
was an elephant
but most of like Oscar and uh and Telly
Telly what was it that was the name
right Telly and Grover and all that I
think they were just monsters like just
generic monsters you know
talk about a night of clocking
alien something yeah I thought what well
wasn't there like a joke about Gonzo
being like from another plane or
something I always thought he was
supposed to be some kind of bird because
I thought like his nose was kind of like
a beak so I thought he was supposed to
be like kind of a vulture or something I
don't know
it's access for my generation he's the
monkey equivalent of Ed and Eddie I
can't remember that show but it was a
little after my time I think
uh Zach said then the dude realizes he
likes the goat more yeah he's just like
oh yeah okay never mind that girl so you
know but uh I just can't imagine like
what the situation around this whole
village and you know who was doing all
the farming while all of this was going
on that's what I'd like to know I mean
because presumably they still had to
make some money because they're like
well you know that gold from the goddess
still hasn't like materialized so we
still got to grow the corn and beans and
stuff so who's gonna do that well
they're all like [__] goats and
drinking peyote and whatnot somebody's
got to be working
I don't know I think about these things
but you know what I mean
so I don't know like I said I don't know
if she actually came became convinced
that she actually needed blood and that
she needed Human Sacrifice because she
was all in on this Aztec goddess thing
now and so it's basically like well we
need to start sacrificing humans
you know to get Supernatural powers and
to like keep us together forever to like
keep us to let us live forever to make
us Immortal right
so
um basically yeah because that's uh what
the Aztec Miss says right that blood is
the only decent food for the gods and so
she started to believe she was a God I
guess so she's like okay well we got you
guys gotta cough it up now
so essentially what she started doing
after that like after the two guys that
had been to centers had been beaten to
death and you know lynched essentially
she started saying okay well we're we're
gonna um you know again kick this into
high gear and we're gonna go full on
human sacrifice now I know we do animal
sacrifices prior to this but you know
human sacrifices that's where it's at
we're gonna need to keep doing that now
sources differ some some said that she
would anybody that was dissenting she'd
be like yeah kill that [__] or
some said she just picked people at
random I'm kind of leading more toward
maybe picking people at random because
that would seem like scary or like more
arbitrary like more like something a God
would do and honestly like after she
started doing that I would think that
like most people that would dissent
would probably keep their [__] mouth
shut like to keep from getting
sacrificed so I'm thinking she probably
just picked people at random
so this went on for several more weeks
um they know for sure that four people
at least were sacrificed during this
time period
and basically what they would do she
would have the cult members I don't know
if she actually like got in on it
herself or if she just like got off on
getting everyone else to do it I kind of
feel like it was the latter thing
but she would get everybody to like beat
them
to near death
then she'd put him up on the Pike and
then she would cut their hearts out
because you know Aztec yeah so she'd cut
their hearts out while they were still
alive and then she would drain all their
blood and mix it with the stuff and
she'd make everyone drink it she did
that herself
evidently evidently
but um yeah so it so it did uh it did
get into Temple of Doom territory in
case you were wondering she did start
cutting out people's hearts it was so
great
she must have believed this I'm thinking
that she just lost her [__] mouth
that she went completely delusional yeah
um and like I said just the power just
went completely to her head she had
never experienced anything like this
everyone listening to her everyone doing
exactly what she said no matter how
horrible she must have convinced herself
that she was an Aztec goddess she did
seem to believe it I mean from
everything that I've read but it was
Destiny her Destiny was finally
fulfilled right it's like okay yeah
because it's like oh I'm destined for
better than her life was before
Christ
but yeah
so um so this went on for several weeks
in early 1963.
and uh as I said they were cutting out
people's hearts uh right there near the
end
now how this whole this whole show
got exposed and ended up
One Night in May of 1963. there was a 14
year old kid he didn't live in yerba
buena I don't think but he just lived in
the area you know and his name was
Sebastian Guerrero
and he was just out doing teenage boy
[__] just like kind of wandering around
and you know just [__] around
and he happened to wander close by the
cave where all of the ritual uh
sacrificing was going on
and he got curious because you know
normally no one was in these caves and
they were usually empty and he just kind
of saw lights flickering and he thought
like he heard weird noises like
animalistic kind of noises were like
chanting or something he's like what the
[__] is that I need to go like check
that out
because this is like a horror movie it's
like if it was me I'd be like nope not
not getting involved but uh this kid
like I said this kid in a way is kind of
like a hero but um yeah
so he gets curious so he decides he's
gonna go over there and see what he can
see
so he kind of goes over to where the
cave is but he and he sees people in
there it's kind of dark and he can't
really tell what they're doing and he's
like well I don't really want them to be
able to see me so he like kind of ducks
behind a rock and he's like peeking
around a rock like watching him in there
now apparently the first thing he sees
he sees first like a bunch of people who
all look like they're you know having an
orgy so they'll look like they're
humping on the floor or whatever just
hit me what this is where Bruce
Dickinson got the lyrics or [__]
Bruce Dickinson and guys from Iron
Maiden got the lyrics for [__] Number
of the Beast
is exactly out of the [__] song is
that I don't remember the words he
[__] he sees a damn Satanic ritual
with chanting and all kinds of human
sacrifice and what is it what am I
seeing was it some crazy dream it sounds
it sounds like yeah maybe this is where
yeah yeah it was like right out of
number because like I said he just
noticed this flickering like Yeah from
the cave and he didn't know what it was
it sounds just like the lyrics of The
Number of the Beast
well now you know they just made it more
Anglo
they did they made more Anglo well more
about Christianity and seeing Satan and
[__] but it's basically the same thing
Zach said I just read that there's a
Belgian rock band named after this crazy
[__] yeah there is
there is but uh like I said she's not
she hasn't really seeped into the
cultural Consciousness the same way that
some other serial killers and like other
True Crime cases have even though this
is [__] crazy but like you said that
might very well be where they got the
idea for those lyrics though yeah it
doesn't say that on the Wikipedia page
but it sounds like you might want to add
that but yeah so he's peeking around
like I said if first thing he sees like
a bunch of people humping on the floor
right like having a origin he's just
like oh what the [__] you know what I
mean like he's not really entirely sure
what he's looking at and then he sees
evidently
um you know a person like up on the Pike
and I'm guessing that he actually saw
somebody like getting their heart cut
out or you know and getting bled and
like everybody drinking the blood
and as soon I mean obviously he's in
shock like watching because he's like
what the [__] am I looking at and then
like when he's 14 you know what I mean
and then once he figured out he's like
holy [__] I know what I'm looking at and
then he like takes off running like just
he's like holy [__] I gotta tell
somebody about this Now The Story Goes
that he ran
flat out for 15 miles yeah because
that's where the nearest police station
was there wasn't a police station like
near there so he just ran and ran
because he was freaked out as you would
be like you just like see a cave it's
like I wonder what's going on in there
holy [__] you know what I mean that's
not what you're expecting to see you
know what I mean yeah it's right out of
the song man he turned and ran yeah
that's that's it turned and ran and what
did I see you know what I mean [__] it
was it just some crazy dreams yeah it's
running a song man that must be who he's
talking about they're talking about
Sebastian garage after his show after
the show you can listen to that song you
go yeah that's what they're talking
about it might be yeah but he's going
666 the Number of the Beast sacrifice is
going on tonight you know it's kind of a
generic song really by today's standards
but it's exactly this second same
situation yeah yeah
that kid would have been tripped the
[__] out
like what the [__] are they doing well
yeah because like I said he's like a
small town kid he's 14 he's just
wandering around he's never seen
anything like that in his entire well
most people haven't seen anything like
that in their entire life pretty like 99
of people on Earth would be [__]
freaked out that would be mind-bending
to a teenager right what the [__] maybe
it'd probably even be harder on an adult
yeah you'd be like no it can't be yeah
they got to be making a movie I'm gonna
go down there and talk to him there's
some weird [__] like that
it can't be real I'm gonna wrap this
[__] up Hey where's Tom savini yeah you
go in there yeah yeah and then they cut
your arm out yeah but yeah so so yeah
this kid runs 15 miles
to the nearest town or the nearest town
that had a police station
which is called uh via gron I guess yeah
big big villain big big Village yeah
that's a real creative name so that's a
real creative big Village Little Village
the medium-sized
[Laughter]
slightly larger than the other ones
really yeah that's that's what they're
all called It's just in a row you know
so so he finally gets to the police
station after running 15 miles freaked
out exhausted he goes in there and he's
kind of hysterical which like I said I
guess you would be and he's telling the
cops and pretty much he can't really
explain like what it is that he saw and
I guess he said something that had to do
with vampires which to in his defense
that's what they were doing they were
drinking blood so technically that
that's right but that's vampires okay
but I guess because he said it like that
or like he was just seemed like
hysterical so a lot of the cops were
just like whatever kid you know what I
mean they just thought that he was
making it up or you know that he was on
something or something like they just
didn't believe it because and the [__]
that he was saying was just so crazy
they're like there's no way that that
could be true
so they didn't really do anything
immediately
so he was kind of there all night I
guess
but one of the officers there whose name
was Luis Martinez
um he basically kind of felt bad for the
kid and he's like well you know hang
around and I'll you know take you home
in the morning
whatever like I'm presuming in his car
now while Luis was taking the kid home
the next day and I'm guessing that
Sebastian at this point had kind of like
calmed down enough to kind of tell him a
little bit more about it and he's like I
can show you where it happened like I
can show you where the cave was
so Luis goes okay well we're gonna go
check it out because I guess he did kind
of like believe him or he's like well
the kid is obviously like really scared
so something so something really bad
must have happened so probably we should
check it out even all the all the other
costumes better take a gun I mean I tell
him you better take a gun [__] it that's
what I would have been telling that cop
well yeah get that [__] shotgun ready
yeah yeah I mean that's what I would
have said too yeah so he basically took
him to uh presumably where the cave was
to show him where the thing was
sadly
neither one of them was heard from again
what
yeah they got a job they weren't seen
alive again that was for sure they did
find him later on but all right
so it didn't have a happy ending it did
not okay it did not
now
not too long after I don't know if it
was just like later that same day or the
next day the other cops were like hey
um you guys see Martinez like he went
out there with that kid and they were
maybe going to check out that cave and
uh he didn't come back and the kid
didn't come back either so probably not
good so I guess the cops finally got off
their asses and like did a little bit of
investigation and it turned out that um
some of the towns around yerba buena I
guess there had been some kind of like
little Rumblings or
rumors or something of like satanic
Cults in the area
so the cops were like oh [__] probably
we should have taken the [__] seriously
right uh especially now that their
colleague has not returned and they
can't raise him on the radio or anything
like that so they kind of start to freak
out a little bit
so on May 31st of 1963 the cops are like
okay we need to go check this [__] out
they even and they even went um they got
the Army like the military to come in as
well
and so they all go in uh to do like a
big operation in yerba buena
now they roll into town the first place
they go is The Farmhouse where Magdalena
and her brother elizar had been living
now they found both of them
stoned out of their gourds just kind of
laying in the bed so they were like oh
that was easy so they just picked the
two of them up
um yeah they were they were completely
like completely High
now Santos one of the Hernandez Brothers
he either tried to like sources differ
he either tried to attack the police
like jumped at him or tried to run away
uh in at which point the cops shot him
dead so he got shot and killed
uh cayetano Hernandez they were looking
around for him because they were like
okay well we got these two chuckle [__]
and then it's like you know we just shot
this one where's the other brother
turned out the other brother cayetano
had been killed previously by a member
of the cult named Jesus Rubio
now
I was listening to like a podcast
earlier and they said you know you would
think that Jesus had was kind of like a
hero and he killed kayatan it was like
you [__] you made us do all this
horrible [__] and he killed him but
apparently that wasn't what it was Jesus
actually wanted in on the action he
actually wanted to be like let into the
high class of priests or whatever so he
could be protected and he wouldn't be
sacrificed so he was basically trying to
save his own ass so he created this cult
yes so they so they went to kayatano he
went to cayetano and said hey can I get
out of this priest action
um I know you guys are faking I'm not
gonna tell anybody if you let me in on
it cayetana said no absolutely not and
so he sees actions uh killed him damn so
that's uh that's how that went so that's
it that's special yeah these are all
like really lovely people aren't they so
uh so yeah uh and weirdly most of the
rest of the cult members which like I
said was a significant portion if not
all of the villagers pretty much hold
themselves up in the caves
and engaged in a shootout with police
during which many of them were killed I
don't think any of the other cops were
killed Louise other than the first cop
that went out there but um several of
the occult members were killed in the
shootout as was one of the Hernandez
brothers who was killed earlier
um so basically so they searched around
in the farm or near The Farmhouse where
they had found
um Magdalena and her brother like
[__] Stone to other Mayans they found
the dismembered bodies of Sebastian
Guerrero the 14 year old kid who had
reported them to the police very bravely
and look how that ended up and uh Luis
Martinez the cop so I guess yeah and
Luis Martinez also had his heart torn
out okay that was the kid no that was
the cop the cop that was the cop
so they found those two bodies uh near
the farm where the where Magdalene and
her brother were arrested somebody said
who gave them guns I think you could I
think I think Mexicans could have guns
in the 60s I mean everybody seemed to
have them like all the villagers had
them they were farmers so I guess and
like all the cops had them too I think a
real hardcore gun control supposedly
happened later on in Mexico 70s maybe
80s but it doesn't matter you can get
let's go swimming and guns so is Brazil
abandoned them doesn't mean [__] this is
America they'll they can [__] make a
back ten out of nothing
well like I said I'm presuming uh this
Village like it seemed like a lot of the
villagers had shotguns and things like
that because like I said they're Farmers
yeah but a lot of farmers have shotguns
so uh so yeah
so like I said big firefight so they did
find those two bodies uh they also
searched all around the cave like where
the most of the rituals had taken place
and they found uh another six bodies
which had all been dismembered some of
them had also had their hearts removed
so yeah
um and they they might have been more
than that they're not entirely sure
those were just the ones that they found
now this is crazy but Magdalena and
eliezar uh you know the brother and
sister
they went to trial
and they only got
50 years which
is mind-blowing she only got 50 years 50
years now they were now we should know
they were only
um convicted of the two murders the 14
year old kid and the cop all right
because
all the other murders
um none of the cult members would
testify against them none of them
um which is crazy even after all that
[__] they still wouldn't couldn't turn
on her they still wouldn't turn on her
and say yeah she did all that [__] they
were accomplices well that yeah that too
well and the thing about it was that
after like the whole the story came out
and everything like that because you
know they had the kids testimony they
had like other [__] going on and I think
maybe some people did like dissent and
like say what was going on up there but
the um the cult members the villagers
that weren't killed in the shootout
um several of them were also convicted
each of them I believe got 30 years each
uh for their part in it because they
participated like I said I don't think
other than the heart cutting out which I
think that maybe um Magdalena did all of
the deaths like the beatings and
everything like that I'm pretty sure she
just told everybody else to do that and
they did it for her yeah so I don't know
I mean that doesn't mean she didn't like
kill people she did but I'm just saying
that you know I don't know if she got
her hands dirty to any great extent so
uh so yeah so nobody would testify but
they all all the leftover ones got 30
Years anyway
um and basically that's where it's where
it kind of ended up I don't know
whatever ended up happening to some of
the cult members like served their time
and then they got out and a couple of
them like talked about it there are some
Spanish language uh articles about it
floating around out there I don't know
what happened to Eleazar
um I'd you know whether he served his
sentence and got out I'm not entirely
sure how old he was he wasn't much older
than Magdalena Magdalena who was only I
believe only 18 at the time that she was
arrested
um she would have got a 50-year sentence
I heard that she died in prison but
nobody is entirely sure when or what
exactly happened to her so it's entirely
possible that she could have served her
time and gotten out like as an old woman
um and nobody remembered anything about
it but most sources I saw said that she
probably died in prison but I don't
think there's any record of that because
no one's entirely sure even like the
Wikipedia page and everything like that
they think she was born around 1947 but
the death date they have no idea like
when when she died they just know when
she was arrested and then they just kind
of like lost track so
yeah
um what's the moral of the story moral
of the story says if anybody shows up in
your town and says we're gonna give you
all the money if you do anything we say
don't do that thing whatever it is they
want don't do it just don't do it and
especially if they say that some
Supernatural shit's gonna happen if you
especially don't do it then right and I
think I talked about this like on the
televangelist show and stuff like that
too anybody says they know what some God
is talking about or like they know they
have some direct pipeline to like some
Supernatural already [__] that [__]
don't ever listen to anybody who says
anything like that they're only just
trying to get you to do [__] that you
don't want to do they're trying to get
all your money and tell people that I
know but I'm just saying well evidently
you do because it's like some people
still do it yeah anytime anybody says
that it's always a grift always
I mean because there's no way
of proving otherwise you know how long
we've been on
hour and 23 minutes why don't you go
ahead and hit commercials and then we'll
uh we'll come back after commercials
okay I mean the story is mostly done but
we will do an after party okay we'll do
an after party yeah
so we're gonna do a little set of
commercials and then we'll be back in
just a few minutes yep
[Music]
of the room
died
[Music]
foreign
it's good
[Music]
foreign
well it wouldn't have made any sense but
well the thing about it was that
this story doesn't make any sense yeah I
mean the thing about it is that this
woman Magdalena
had this not happened had she not been
recruited into being
koalaku
um and going into this town to like try
to Griff these people out of their money
would she have done would she have
become this bloodthirsty [__]
essentially serial killer no probably
not no she's been a hooker but yeah she
probably just would have been a hooker
and died young yeah like you know I'm
assuming
well she died young because she was in
prison
if she yeah if she did then yeah no I
think a little long time she probably
wouldn't have died you know probably
just live a normal life
normal for hooker you know but that's
probably what she would have been normal
hook or life yeah just hook your life
yeah but it's just it's interesting
though the way
circumstances conspired
in pretty much the worst way they could
have conspired
and she had to have had something
I figured she had something wrong with
her psychologically obviously
two of you because I think you could put
other people in that situation it
wouldn't go down that way you know what
I mean
she was young and she was role playing
and she had a bad background and all of
a sudden she got a bunch of power and
went to her head and she didn't know she
became a God yeah she'd rather be a
goddess yeah and she just got off on
yeah y'all it's like man I'll make
people do the most [__] up [__] he
made me do [__] you need to now it's
time for you I kind of feel like it
might have been as simple as that yeah I
was thinking that like I was listening
to a podcast about it on the way home
today
and I thought that very thing I said she
probably got treated really badly you
know at in her uh you know being a sex
worker and she's probably like well I'm
gonna get one back on the [__] world
yeah for treating me like this you know
what I mean and then she's probably
started to buy into it I was destined
for this I am and I am the new goddess
yeah that's right yes look at all this
power I have yeah they'll do whatever I
say like I can tell them to do like I
can tell them to like rape a goat or
like have sex with their daughter and
they'll do it without even questions
that's right this is gonna spread
throughout the world and I'm gonna run
the whole world that's probably exactly
what she's thinking she's dumb she got
like mad with power yeah she's young and
dumb you know she's about 18. yeah
you're probably talking like 75 80 IQ
you know [__] yeah she probably
believes her own [__] at this point
you know I Am The Reincarnation of this
goddess
that's crazy basically the goddess are
talking about it's kind of like Tiamat
or Kali
like you said temple to do you know
Kali
the Kali also had a damn necklace of
skulls and I think of hands yeah wasn't
it didn't she have like a I think yeah
now that you're thinking about it Kali
has I think she had like a little skirt
or like a little thing like a little
arms and skirt it was arms right arms I
think so yeah and then I think she had
like a little necklace that was like
heads heads and skulls or something then
she had what forearms
human heart and then one also had kind
of like a like a flower like a Lotus
yeah and I can't remember what was on
the other hand
I looked it up a lot because I was gonna
do it for Halloween one year until I
found out that the logistics of it were
too complicated
to become Kali yeah yeah it would have
been cool though well I could have I
could figure out all the other stuff but
I was like how am I gonna do like four
arms so that it looks stupid it's gonna
look stupid what you do is you put on a
back brace you know how those little
back things to clip on where you put the
wings instead of wings coming out you
have another set of arms yeah I need
like mannequin arms and they'd be
mannequins they wouldn't move yeah
that's how you do well it'd be better
than having like [__] floppy ass yeah
it couldn't flap because that would look
really you have one arm hold a dagger
another arm with a heart in it or
something yeah
and then I was mad because like I
thought about doing that for so many
years said you know what I can afford it
I'm totally gonna do that because I
never saw anybody be like do that
costume but then like a few years after
that I started thinking about that I saw
that [__] model Heidi Klum and she
did it yeah and it was awesome yeah and
I was like that she had all the money to
put that's what I mean it's like you
know my broke ass I couldn't like afford
to do it but I was like hers looked
badass like she painted herself all blue
and everything it was super cool
um are we doing goth Easter goth Easter
what's that
we might get some Easter candy
yeah we don't eat just not like a really
big
I mean even when I was growing up it's
like you get like an Easter basket and
stuff but it's like and I'd go to my
aunt's house and we'd have like an egg
hunt goth Easter
so when you take these little black eggs
but they're actually like musical Benoit
balls and you put them up inside
and then you tell everybody look for
them
yeah it's the dirty egg that's the dirty
yeah that's what that's that's that's
what the goth version Oh my God that
would just gave me an idea for you
remember when we go to go to that
monthly fetish party like an escape why
did they ever do that for Easter yeah
they got these little golf buddies like
the egg little God buddy like an egg
hunt like figure yeah
[__] tacky it's just tacky man well
that was kind of their whole that was
their whole thing
I mean at that one party you like had to
stick your face in a
kitty litter box like yeah stuff yeah
with Tootsie Rolls in it all right so
you want to go ahead and call it uh
quits on the show Jim I reckon I thought
you said we're gonna have an after party
but I guess the Apple party but I guess
it was like nine o'clock yeah it's nine
o'clock and he
he woke me up last night yeah because he
he was out um he went out to Bike Night
so I just stayed home I did my laundry
and I you know had some pizza he left
some pizza for me and then I got some
more pizza oh really yeah two slices
okay yeah I'll have one of them yeah and
then I sat down and watched a really
weird Irish uh horror movie on shutter
which is called isolation which I might
do a review of because I kind of dug it
but it was a weird premise but I kind of
dug it so um so I kind of watched that
and then I fell asleep and then I
watched cold case files and then I fell
asleep like about 10 10 30.
and I kind of heard him coming home but
I was like half asleep
and then at like one what was it one or
one Thirty in the morning yeah about
that I suddenly heard this woman's voice
in the room like really loud like and I
was like what the [__] and like I sat up
and I looked around and there was nobody
in the room and I was like what the [__]
and then I figured oh that must have
been Tom and like I went down the hall
and he was like in his man cave going I
came in the room with this and I didn't
freaking and I didn't have my headphones
weren't on or the points wasn't
connected was it connected to a
commercial so it went to a commercial it
was like super loud and then I guess
before I even sat up like he had run out
the room so I was like I was confused
for a second trying to set up and I was
like who was that trying to get the damn
Bluetooth headphones to connect
[Laughter]
so it was 1 30 and I was like God damn
it I was like now I gotta go back to
sleep because I have to get up at like
five in the morning
so you know what I mean
um let's see Zach says Whoa shortest
show ever
not really I don't think it's the
shortest show we've done we've done
we've done our shows before I mean we've
done movie reviews and stuff like that
or shorter so like I said this wasn't a
super super complicated case you know
which is probably good
um we're gonna be back on Friday because
yeah and Friday night we can do a much
longer show because I don't have to go
to bed early
you know what I mean unless you want to
go out Friday oh we're gonna go out
Friday oh we are stated
I know
but but we can do a little show before
we go
yeah okay
but yeah okay so hopefully you guys uh
enjoyed that show I had a good time with
it it was a pretty [__] up story now
we're gonna go listen to that song and
see if that is what they're talking
about you're pretty sure that's what
they're talking about you you can put it
on it's all about the same situation
you'll see okay this thing this thing's
got speakers done it
okay
uh Camp guy said there was a female
Mexican wrestler who killed lots of old
lady widows huh like I said we should
probably do some more Mexican cases
because there have been like some really
weird ones we got a lot of Mexican fans
that's true yeah so we should probably
it's close to us man it's because we
should probably cover some more of that
down south
yeah yeah it's just a little bit South
yeah but yeah so uh thank you everybody
for dropping by and hanging out with us
this evening talking about this [__]
up [__] and uh we will be back on Friday
night for our Sidetrack show probably
about 7 30 again like usual please
remember to like share all of that other
stuff comment that helps too uh with the
algorithm and everything like that uh so
we will see you guys again on Friday
night
good night